what's up guys so if you guys are
setting up crazy setup with many
monitors then you guys notice that on
the back of the graphics cards there's
only display ports may be a few HDMI
ports and most often a DVI - deport and
if you guys are setting up like six
monitors or something crazy like that
you're gonna have to check for auto
populate all of the courts as a result
you're gonna need a DVI - D to HDMI
cable if your monitor doesn't support
you guys - D in so today I have a DVI to
HDMI cable and I'm gonna be seeing
what's inside the package and see how it
works let's jump right in so guys the
HDMI to DVI cable comes in a single bag
take a zip lock cover this love warranty
card and there's over some tokens
there's a similar cover on this as well
there's a little tight pulling it
together
you get the Panthers okay people coming
so that's the cable guys that's email
performance well guys this here was very
easy setup you just plug in the DVI end
into the graphics card or motherboard
and you plug in the HDMI cable apart
into your monitor and it works straight
out of the box
there's no drivers and you have to
install or anything you're tweaking the
bio stuff like that it's just work
out of the box one thing that you guys
should remember when you're shopping
around for this stuff is that make sure
that you guys are getting the right
direction as in you're getting DVI to
HDMI and not HDMI to DVI there's a lot
of those cables as well and a lot of
times they are not bi-directional so
make sure you guys are careful of that
when you're shopping around make sure
that it's a bi-directional or exactly
which direction that you want also do it
keep in mind that DVI ports do not
output sound so if you guys have
monitors that have speakers and you're
planning on using them just make sure if
you can in mine you might need an
absolute cable to plug in to your
monitor if your motor supports that well
guys that was my quick unboxing and
overview of the DVI to HDMI cable and if
you guys are in a market for this you
guys are probably also looking for a
DisplayPort to HDMI cable so if you guys
are interested in that make sure to
check out my video on that where I unbox
it overview a DisplayPort to HDMI cable
but that's all for now guys if you like
this video and make sure to give it a
like if you guys loved it and would like
to see more videos just like this make
sure to subscribe it or not double
implication but until next time guys bye